[Musique]
oui
j'étais de toute façon très
intéressé par le monde ella fitzgerald
aretha franklin voilà et du coup c'est
c'était c'était ses morceaux qui me
collait à la peau moi je prenais des
cours de jazz je commençais en fait la
guitare jazz à l'époque je prenais des
cours est donc ça m'a intéressé
d'intégrer le groupe pour appliquer ce
que je faisais ce que j'apprenais en
cours pour notre but c'est un petit peu
ça c'est de prendre un répertoire plutôt
à majorité on va dire jazz et blues mais
pas seulement un peu de pop aussi un peu
de chansons et de leur pensée de trouver
des idées dessus pour les détourner un
peu pour pour être un peu plus créatifs
ce quatuor aux rythmes jazzy se rend une
fois par semaine dans les studios de
répétition de la batterie de guyancourt
ouvert il ya 14 ans ils permettent à des
musiciens de venir s'exercer dans des
salles complètement équipée quand la
batterie a vu le jour je me suis dit il
faut absolument qu'on saisit cette
opportunité d'avoir un studio ici il ya
trois studios de répétition qu'on peut
louer à l'heure
voilà en groupe
en solo ou en duo sans les locaux tout
entièrement équipée
la musiciens viennent avec leurs
instruments simplement il ya sono sur
place les amplis on a une chance de
dingue le matériel est de très bonne
qualité les régisseurs et toute l'équipe
de la batterie sont extrêmement
sympathique il ya une bonne ambiance
tout est fait pour pour faire de la
musique dans des très bonnes conditions
c'est la bulle d'oxygène de la semaine
pour nous quatre je pense un
comme ce sont une trentaine de groupes
qui viennent régulièrement répété ici à
majorité et pop rock ils sont
essentiellement amateurs en plus des
lieux ils peuvent bénéficier de l
expertise du personnel présent dans les
studios on a également la chance d'avoir
à disposition si on le souhaite des
conseils prestations scéniques
composition il ya différents ateliers
selon les années on va que les groupes
régler le son nom si besoin on peut leur
poser éventuellement les coacher
[Musique]
la batterie mais également à disposition
un studio d'enregistrement de live
disponible sur une journée et elle
propose des soirées studio en scène pour
que les groupes locataires puissent se
produire devant un public à la batterie
[Musique]